so my name is Ben Smith I work at Google
on the chrome team and more specifically
on the web assembly team so I'm here to
talk a little bit about web assembly
here's the basic layout of the talk I'm
going to talk a little bit about whether
somebody have a sort of web assembly 101
and then I'm going to talk about an
example where I'm gonna use web assembly
in node with a thing called brought Lee
and then I'm going to talk about how
those things go together webassembly and
nodejs
and by the way for the people who are
gonna get a little bored because I do
have a lot of assembly probably more
than Rachel did I drew some little
squiggles on the screen so you can look
at those instead so here's one thing
that's very cool web assembly is enabled
by default in node 8 LTS which means you
can use it right now if you're using
node 8 so why would you use it though
what's the purpose of it well we'll get
back to that first I kind of want to
give you an idea of what it is
so web assembly is this project that a
number of browsers we got together and
we started talking about like well what
if we had a different execution engine
that wasn't JavaScript we could you know
we love JavaScript there's a lot of
great things about JavaScript I mean
this is a JavaScript conference I'm not
gonna say JavaScript is it's great it's
awesome but it does have some things
that are maybe not exactly what you
would want like and I'll and I'll get
into some of that later and so we
started to talk as a group and recently
earlier this year we launched web
assembly in chrome and firefox and very
recently Safari 11 and edged chakracore
also support web assemblies so we're
very very excited about this this is
actually kind of one of these things
that doesn't really happen on the web
which is kind of sad but like everybody
getting together and saying ok well
let's all launch it together so we're
very very excited about this we have a
community group where we
come up with new ideas that we can add
to the language and we also have this
github site where basically anybody can
contribute we do all of our work out in
the open in terms of the spec we have a
reference interpreter so that you can
run web assembly and see what it works
what it looks like and so on so this is
what web assembly org says web assembly
is and I kind of like this quote and I
kind of don't like this quote and the
problem with this quote is that it's
like you look at it and you're like so
wait what's the noun what's the actual
thing that it is right new portable size
and loaded time efficient format
suitable for oh it's format you're like
well what does that mean well so I'll
break it down in a second but the way I
like to think of it is that it's it's an
executable format like JavaScript but
it's a it's primarily a binary format
and that's really important
the reason why we wanted it to be a
binary format is so that it could be
size and load time efficient so I'm
gonna go through the the words here so
when we say portable we mean portable in
the same way that JavaScript is portable
you expect it to basically run
everywhere you know earlier talk from
Gordon about s Perino it's running on
microcontrollers it runs everywhere well
we wanted to have a similar goal like if
web assembly is going to be on the web
it needs to be able to run everywhere
and so that means it should be able to
run on any number of different os's any
numer different Isis and every any
number of different JavaScript engines
as well and non JavaScript engines so
I've listed JavaScript engines up here
but there are a number of people who
have been implementing their own non-web
implementations we actually like the
idea that it's simple enough that you
know one developer can write their own
interpreter write their own JIT even if
they want to so that's very very cool
it's also size and load time efficient
so what we found was that minified
javascript is actually quite small but
you can do better in terms of size so
what we focused on was trying to make it
so that we had a format that was small
but also
compressible another benefit is that
javascript is actually kind of a
difficult language to parse I mean not
particularly difficult it's not like C++
or anything which is notoriously
difficult to parse but it's not as easy
as it could be and so one of the things
we wanted to do with web assembly is
make it so that it was faster parse and
then fast to validate and I'll talk a
little bit about validation later and
then also be able to generate good code
quality like consistently consistent
code quality so that's kind of what size
and load time-efficient means and then
suitable for compilation this is kind of
the crux this is the reason we call it
web assembly it's actually not a very
good name because it's not really an
assembly it's more like web machine code
but that doesn't really sound as good so
it's meant to be a compilation target
you're not meant to write it by yourself
and when I show you some of the examples
you'll see why it's it's very verbose
but that's because it's assembly
language you're not meant to write I
mean well unless that's 6502 and and
you're super awesome so currently the
language that we support are C C++ and
rust we also have some experimental
support for the languages like C sharp
in Java some a lot of people are very
excited about the opportunity to be able
to to basically take their their
language their preferred language and
compile that and then ship that to the
web as a client and in the future we're
planning to add a number of other
languages as well we'd like to really
work with language designers and
existing languages so that we can
compile to their language or compile
their language to web assembly and be
able to to run that so if you know
anybody or if you are a person who's
like I'd like to run web assembly please
talk to us come come to the web assembly
CG and we'd love to talk and so of
course this is a node conference but web
assembly the original idea was about it
being for the web and so some of the
things that are necessary for for a
website is that it has to be sandbox you
don't want to run into a situation where
you just take an executable and
run it on somebody's computer right that
would be horrible I think of the
security issue so we want to make sure
that it's it's a safe executable and and
you can be you can be certain that you
run it and it's not gonna you know
format your hard drive
another thing that's super important is
then needs to have synchronous
interoperability with JavaScript I mean
javascript is the language of the web
right and web assembly isn't meant to
supplant it so it needs to be able to
communicate with JavaScript all the
JavaScript API is and that's true for
note as well and like I said it's also
useful in non web scenarios such as
nodejs so when we talk about javascript
and web assembly this is kind of what
people often think they're like oh well
you know javascript and web somebody
they're really fighting right like web
simply is gonna take over javascript and
like no no this is this is not how we
think of it I think we think of it more
like this like JavaScript and web
assembly are like in a dance ok maybe
not like in a dance but you know what I
mean like they work together they're
meant to be used together using web
assembly for what it's good and good at
and using JavaScript for what it's good
at so but I need to talk about some of
the differences and so I had no idea how
to draw XOR so sorry about that so
imagine that you have this JavaScript
function really simple function right
this is adding two numbers but is it I
mean I know you've all seen this kind of
code before it's not just adding two
numbers you can add string in a number
or an array in a number or you can add
you can add all sorts of different types
and your JavaScript engine has to deal
with this and actually one of the
reasons why javascript is you know
somewhat difficult language to compile
and you know my colleague Benedict is
probably gonna get upset because I'm
gonna paper over all of the complexities
of JavaScript but one of the things
that's difficult about it is that when
you write a piece of code in JavaScript
it doesn't really know what the types
are for that function yet
so it has to run a few times and then it
says oh well you're mostly calling with
numbers okay well optimize for numbers
and then once we have that code
optimized we'll check every time you
call it to make sure that you're still
calling with numbers and if you ever
call it with something that's not a
number then we bail out and then we do
something special and there's tricks to
do that but it's it adds some complexity
to the code so this is what webassembly
looks like and you can see it's quite a
bit more verbose and another thing you
might see is that it has types specified
so the I 32 is a 32-bit integer type and
it has specified operations for 32-bit
types so what this is saying is take a
32-bit number take another 32-bit number
add them together as parameters so it's
the exact same function but it's written
in webassembly
that slide should have been before but i
guess i can say these are the only types
that we have there's a 32-bit integer
there's a 64-bit integer there's a
floating 30-feet 32-bit float and a
64-bit float also for people who have
been writing javascript for a while the
64-bit float it's pretty nice
you're gonna get it soon you're gonna
get it soon but we have it now so so the
cool thing about what we have when we
have this limited set of types is that
we can do validation on our code so when
you take that code and you compile it
and you instantiate it in the browser
what happens is it does a validation
pass over over the code and it says does
everything make sense do all the types
like sort of add up in the way that I
expect and if they don't it just it
won't compile so what you see here is a
call operations this is the actual call
instruction that webassembly has and if
you pass it a float or if you pass it
and in 64 and then in 32 then it says
nope that looks wrong to me I don't I
don't know if these are you have to put
an explicit cast in again another reason
why you probably don't want to write
this and right hand it's it's tedious
but this gives you the benefit of the
compiler of the benefit of being able to
say okay well
I know exactly all the types so that
function I can turn into one instruction
probably maybe two and like that's very
powerful it knows exactly what's right
there alright so let's look at a little
bit more complex example this is a
JavaScript function I don't know if this
is how everyone would write it but you
know okay so we're gonna add up a bunch
of values in an array and then return
the result really really simple stuff so
the thing is in WebP assembly you don't
get arrays and objects and all the other
stuff what you get is one big bag of
bytes it's like an array buffer we call
it linear memory and so you have to sort
of treat memory differently again
another reason why you probably don't
want to like write this by hand it's a
little tedious so this is a sort of
JavaScript version using typed arrays
that's a little closer to how you might
implement it in web assembly so
basically what's happening here is we've
got our array of bytes and then we put
values in in order and we haven't a big
in and an end and that's kind of like
our array right and then we'll loop
through and we'll access our value and
then we'll add up the results and then
return the answer and so then you could
basically instantiate your u8 array call
your function pass in your range and
then you get your result right everybody
get it alright so this is the most
humbly equivalent low to that it's a
little bit nasty and maybe you can't
even read it I don't know it's a little
small but I'll go through the pieces and
just sort of give you an idea again this
is just to sort of give you a flavor of
what it looks like
so this first part here this is the dual
do-while part of the of this of the the
code so there's a loop at the top and at
the bottom there's like a branch back to
the top it's conditional branch back to
the top so that's how you sort of
represent a loop and this LTS here that
that's the signed at less than
comparison I love this stuff it I'm I'm
I'm watched looking at everybody's faces
to see if your
attention or if you're tuning out at
this point so you know there's gonna be
a quiz at the end this part right here
this is basically doing the result plus
equal usually you eight array begin part
so that's essentially saying set local
is like take this local variable and set
its value then add is saying add these
two numbers get locals saying get this
that get this value add to a value that
I pulled from the memory that's what
load eight U is so this is the sort of
operations that's actually doing this um
and then finally this is the one that's
doing the increment this is like begin
plus plus so you can see again it's sort
of a set local get local add thing
that's happening here and that's
basically the whole thing so then
there's a return result at the end and
then that's your that's your entire
function so then in webassembly you also
have to sort of it's a it's a contained
module basically webassembly will never
do anything it can't do anything to your
javascript environment that you don't
allow it to basically have to import
anything you want to call and you have
to export any any functions you want to
make available to the environment so
that's what we're doing here we have a
memory that we're importing from outside
and then we have a function that we're
also exporting outside and so then all
you get from your module just like a
JavaScript module is the imports and the
exports so this is kind of what the
binary would look like this is the
actual binary it's 80 bytes again I love
this stuff but you know I'll move
through it quickly because I'm running
not too bad on time so there's a little
header here here you can sort of see the
strings there's that my mom and the sum
and then this is the function at the end
it's just the rest of this stuff is the
function again I won't go through the
bytes nobody wants that
so then putting it all together
basically this is like in node I ran
this it does work
although someone's probably gonna copy
this from the slide and be like ah you
made a mistake but basically you can see
here like pretty easily you you can
instantiate the memory then just copy
the data and like you did before
then you create this import object
saying which modules you want to import
and then you instantiate your web
assembly object
then you can call your export that's
what the instance exports some is and
then you can log the result so you know
a little bit more verbose than you would
have with your JavaScript but what
you're getting out of this is is sort of
a separation between the imports and the
exports so using web assembly with node
let's take a look at some of the stuff
you can do the some of the stuff that I
tried out so one of the things I wanted
to try out was this was brought laid
bratli is really cool because it's this
compression format it's actually really
popular on the web people are using
instead of gzip because it's it usually
gets a little bit better compression and
so I wanted to see what it was like
there's actually a number of node
libraries that do this already
there's broadly Jas there's uilt orb
there's actually a JavaScript
implementation in the brought lis repo
as well and I wanted to see what a
webassembly implementation would look
like so I decided to try it out so
here's the steps that I went through
downloaded brought Lee just pulled it
straight from from github I compiled
within description I already had em
script and setup but it's actually
really easy if you just search up search
form script in you can build it right
away or you can just download in and get
access to it a few things that I'm doing
here
broadly is compiled with CMake so I pass
in a tool chain file which basically
says instead of using your host tool
chain used in script and instead
that's all that's doing then you pass in
this flag here - s wasm what that's
saying - in script in is generate web
assembly code and then finally I say
build the release version of it alright
so I do that and I have some library
files and so the library files are
generates are a decoder and an encoder
and then some common bit that's shared
between the two so if you look at the
API for broadly there's this C function
here and it's pretty simple and actually
gives you exactly what you want it you
basically give it a buffer of data that
you want to compress and a size then you
give it another buffer
which is where to write the data and
then you and it give back the size of
that compressed data so basically what I
did here was I wrote a command which
says compile this library and actually
all it's doing is it's loading that
library in but export a function from
the library so this is a little bit of a
Voodoo there's there's nicer ways to do
this but this is kind of like a simple
sort of one-liner good for a slide all
I'm doing here is I'm saying take these
libraries extract this one function the
function I mentioned before broadly
decoder decompress add in a little
wrapper JavaScript and then spit out a
brought leave Azzam javascript file so
that's what that's what this bit of
function is doing here so then let's
talk a little bit about the jas wrapper
so the javascript wrapper basically
needs to be able to say okay I've got
this web assembly module and I've got
this function that's being exposed but
it's exposed using those API are those
types that I talked about before right I
32 F 32 I 64 F 64 it's not really the
types you want to work with in
JavaScript what we want to work with is
like a node buffer so that's what I'm
doing here is i'm taking the encoded
buffer and in this case i'm just saying
I know what the decoded size will be
that's actually not too uncommon when
you're decoding and what i'm doing here
is like kind of a pseudo c javascript
thing which is a little bit funny so you
can see I have this underscore P after
all the names that's kind of like a
pointer so it's a pointer it's more like
an index into the web some liman memory
you can think of it as being like where
is my buffer in the you know in the web
assembly webassembly linear memory like
I described before so what you can see
there is I'm actually doing malloc and
this is the real C malloc if you write C
or C++ you know this this is well you
shouldn't be using malloc in C C++ but
this is the actual malloc and this is
the actual free so I'm just allocating
the buffers that I need and then
wrapping a try finally and cleaning it
up
if anything goes wrong so then I'm
copying the data into the buffers this
is just standard JavaScript stuff here
there's a little bit of magic you can
see the module Heep u8 that's something
that's exposed by the wrapper code it's
basically the access err into the linear
memory and what I'm doing is taking the
encoded buffer which is the sorry the
the node buffer and I'm just copying the
data directly into memory
the only other trick here is that I have
to sort of write the the size in and so
that's what that second part is doing
there's actually simpler ways to do that
but I'm just I'm trying to keep it as
like like no magic this is like
literally what's happening under the
hood it's just writing bytes into
buffers finally we call the function
passing in all the data that we created
before and then we copy the data back
out right so all that's happening here
is we say okay well we know this this
DES size of the actual decoded buffer
then we copy the buffer back out and
then the node buffer API is a little bit
weird it actually aliases the buffer if
you use buffer from so then we just do
buffer from again and it makes a copy
and that's it actually that that was the
entire wrapper function for decoding and
so just to sort of you know okay shrunk
the punt down a little bit but this is
19 lines of code basically to do the
wrapper for this for this so this is the
part that I was a little bit unhappy
about it's it's not not as fast as the
native bindings it actually is pretty
fast so it's faster than the JavaScript
implementation both of the JavaScript
implementations that I found and there
are some ability there are some options
that are not currently exposed to note
but there are actually going to be
available soon after that allow you to
get some additional performance there
but you can see that the native bindings
are still are still quite a bit faster
at least in this particular case I will
mention that I found that usually this
it's not this this far ahead I noticed
that the it's using sim D actually in
the native code
we don't have sim D currently in
webassembly so that might be some of the
discrepancy so when we have sim D in the
future this this these numbers might
change quite a bit but you can see it's
actually still it's actually pretty good
performance like we're getting 2x so
again for this use case so again
benedict's is probably upset with me
about that so right so the native
bindings are quite a bit faster why
would you use webassembly then what's
the benefit well here's one thing that
I'm super excited about you compile once
you could drop your web assembly module
directly into your your package and
it'll work on any ice ax any VM well
that supports web assembly or any OS
right that's pretty cool you can use
that same module on the web so now you
want to basically take that module and
say oh I'm gonna drop it into my client
do it it'll work you can write the
bindings later in Java JavaScript like
you saw I wrote no C code I wrote C like
JavaScript but it's still JavaScript and
you can write your own like wrappers for
that and there actually are some nice
ones and it's sandboxed right if you use
the native
module well you could basically scribble
memory you can do whatever you want it's
C++ right this is sandbox you can't
break it if you broke it and you'd break
your website and we don't want that so
we're trying hard to make sure that that
doesn't happen and you don't have to
rewrite your C++ libraries like a number
of people already want to do this right
there they're taking libraries and
they're rewriting them in JavaScript
right just take your C code compile it
to a web assembly and then you can drop
it in and you get access to it I'll
mention that I actually tried
sequel Lite as well and I got that
running and it was pretty simple to do
okay so why are some of the reasons why
you might not use webassembly well we
saw it's not as fast as native and it
never will be because it's we're doing
more work we have more bounds checks we
have we have things that we're doing to
try and protect you
and that's probably gonna make it be a
little bit slower we have no direct
access to native libraries so if you
want to basically access something like
for the file system you can't do it
through webassembly like I said before
it's like a it's an encapsulation it
only let it oh can only access what you
give it access to so this is really
about like speeding up computation
that's a that's a big big part of it and
there's no direct access to no js'
modules again it's the same sort of
thing it the webassembly module is it's
kind of its own little universe so
here's some things that we're working on
in the CG of the community group for web
assembly that I'm super excited about
because I'm actually one of the
champions for so sim D like I said some
things to get some additional
performance threads which I know some
people are very excited about and some
people are like why are you doing this
but trust me it's awesome that's the one
I'm the champion for zero cost
exceptions to make exception handling
really fast post binding to make it so
it's easier so that binding layer might
you might not have to write anything
that's that's what that's a feature is
for tail calls some people are very
excited about and then of course garbage
collection which will basically open the
door to any number of new languages and
that one is further out but I think
definitely on everyone's radar that's
the talk I hope you're excited about web
assembly and if you are here's some of
the links and you can of course send me
any questions on Twitter or github as
well thanks so much
[Applause]